allora siamo in via alessandro manzoni
che è la via nella quale è nata
innanzitutto quel giorno tutti quanti
ragazzi ultimo blog sta facendo dei giri
io e gabriele perché ci mancano dei
costumi per il secret santa stasera
oltre a avere diciamo uno dei parenti al
quale fare un regalo per ha deciso anche
di travestirsi da quel parente quindi
siamo qua in questa zona che è piena di
negozi del carnet di carnevale per
trovare il nostro vestito io voglio fare
qualche giro in più che pure parenti
regalo che faccio l'ha attaccata non so
come fare a farlo e gabrielli in tutto
questo è entrato l'ha detto e fatto
se la vedano nel titolo da temere perché
si cura degli stili dal pene allora
abbiamo finito di fare i regali che besi
soddisfatto del tuo costume antico e
cruz che costume interamente eccellente
costruirlo comunque ora stava andando a
fare un regalo a nostro padre che abita
qui in sicilia lo sta vedendo per pranzo
e scavo di fargli visto che un uomo
estremamente maturo vi leggo dei
negativi li facciamo noi ci becchiamo
tutto con tutti quanti diciamo i
fratelli a breve a catania è bloccata
appello e natale nella medio fondo di un
traffico
guardatevi c'è qui ecco mi chiamo
c'è metà facciamoci vedere che ha
abbandonato la famiglia abbandonato la
tua famiglia
è quanto mai stata così felice che cosa
è tutto per me no grazie ma non quello
che volete
questi siamo noi la piccoli cui elmo può
fare che ci ha 50 anni gianluigi lab e
sorvoliamo facce di eroina loro
ammontare sono sempre io spendo parole
che bello sguardo birbante riguarda gli
sensibilità e sensibilità nonostante la
corruzione del mondo la correzione del
mondo lorenzo non è riuscita a smettere
tu metti play e non interrompa il video
di poi ve lo devo sbobinare tutto e sono
due ore di locara mente una cosa da
bambino mio che sensibilità allora
finalmente sto mangiando la cartuccia ta
avrei voluto farvi vedere la cipollina
ma è già finita poi baby un commento
sulla sicilia catanese eccellente da mio
padre ci sta spiegando perché ha deciso
di diventare un mago e perché vuole
darsi buddismo zen serio ai il costume
tutte erano due persone che fanno con la
cinica prima un po siamo tornati a casa
guardate già qui bellezza tirapiedi
italiano vi dico solo che per prepararmi
per il mio santa ci ho messo 40 minuti
buoni quindi più tardi vi faccio vedere
cosa ha fatto prima che c'è quella fine
potrebbe scoprire ragazzi tutti pronti
per la partenza di pronti si no
no no no
non si rende conto me quello è poi vero
cioè si esatto 1 di essa sia laziale
sentiamo ma me lo puoi spendere un
secondo perché è un po tanta roba
all'inizio ecco ci sono delle persone ma
dove gesù non lo trovo c'è un rimbambito
la malattia e la straziata casa è
impressionato nella malattia ma lo per
sorella sì quando è questa collezione di
bubble affari una collezione di babbo
natale legale
altra malattia malattia città giusto
qualche regalo sotto l'albero e mancano
ancora tipo un sacco di regali che abbia
portato noi malattia addirittura una
vista di mattina anzi malattia malattia
malattia malattia
malattia malattia malattia ma l'addio ma
questo si muove malattia la mia malattia
malattia malattia
abbiamo lui e malattia
mia zia la mamma di bravo che andrà
confessato che quando deve togliere
tutto quanto riempie 60 scatoli di che a
60 malattia
andando a vedere ragazzi un secondo
albero dovrebbe essere documentato però
malattia malattia storia giuliana cos'ha
fatto
[Risate]
no
[Applauso]
da qui iniziano a essere dei reperti per
dinosauri fosse un area di rho da parte
di chi non dirò per tutto un
quantitativo di vita da brava c'è un
anello
questo non l'ho pagato io ma lui
impacchettata
[Musica]
[Applauso]
tirate sulle braccia che la signora
giulia
allora questa nella formazione originale
a breve ci travestiamo di uno dal suo
seeker sanità che prenderemo anche il
suo posto 3 2 1 viber
curiale pietrapaolo vittoria è capitato
gabriele me lo sentivo è abbastanza
semplice come costume se con momento
anche perché di più non posso fare se
non spogliarmi e soprattutto tutti i
peli che aveva addosso si creerà tg1
passato l'intera giornata a destinare
rubati a simili san siro e di scorpioni
questo ecco io peso anche la palette di
beatrice per fare il con touring e far
meglio addominale alle mise un marrone e
marrone marrone finiamo sono ha bisogno
uno specchio
direi perfetto esatto ci siamo ci siamo
pronti
[Risate]
[Musica]
[Applauso]
proprio la scusa adesso facciamo sfilata
per loro c'è bisogno cadute le dette con
la fascia con pratesi non certo due
parti
ora ho capito guglielmo dove andavo a
stendere il gioco che aveva cantato
missione compiuta
ragazzi ma non ho visto sono qua io non
ho mai fatto un regalo gabriele quindi
sono un budget più il mio regalo a mio
fratello
ad ogni modo ho dimenticato questo
dettaglio da giungere comunque ragazzi
mi prendo un momento lontano dal casinò
anche così un po in disabili e cosi
facciamo più sono a pezzi
questo blog ma se stato devastante ma
allo stesso tempo è stato forse più
divertente ancora di quello dell'anno
scorso perché mi ha permesso di portarvi
ancora di più nella mia famiglia è una
cosa che ha fatto piacere che mi piace
un po mi mancherà devo essere sincero la
quotidianità il trovarsi ogni giorno a
fare qualcosa e a spingerti possa vivere
un pochino di più perché c'è qualcosa da
mostrare agli altri che sono possibile
superficiale in realtà è molto più
profondo di quanto la si pensa è una
riflessione che faceva questi giorni e
che spesso mi sono reso conto che se non
fosse per il dover offrire sempre
qualcosa di nuovo
sarei rientrato spesso nella routine la
cosa magica di questo dicembre che ogni
giorno è stato diverso questo nuovo anno
voglio che sia così voglio che ogni
giorno si riversa voglio essere un
motivo di crescita
in realtà lo auguro anche a voi ogni
giorno sia migliore e che la nostra vita
possa essere sempre più larga ci
preoccupiamo tanto avere una vita lunga
ma non ci preoccupiamo ma di quanto
larga si accomoda ha detto questo non
vorrei finirlo però non si capisce
perché mi dispiace perché è finita alla
fine non ci credo non ci credo
va bene e facciamo la veloce che è più
facile vi auguro un buon natale e felice
anno nuovo
corsini prenderò una pausa in questi
giorni ma da gennaio si ritorna più
cazzo di prima ciao grazie mille grazie
per un teso
[Musica]